He's one of the best-selling artists of all time
He's won 21
Grammy awards making him one of the most awarded artists all time as well as the most awarded artist for his age
Time magazine named him one of the hundred most influential people in the world
He's Kanye west and here are his [10] rules for success.
I'm not going to sit inside of a corporation for 20 years
The time is now the time is now to Express and for people to believe in themselves
The time is now for it to be okay to be great
people in this world shun people
For being great for being a bright color for standing out
But the time is now to be okay to be the greatest you when this goes [online] or whatever it is
It really matters
And it like really doesn't matter what matters is you know the people who are sparked by it and the people who are like?
Offended by it. It doesn't matter(F*** bleeped) you. You know like because it's about
motivating the doers and
Anyone that wants to sit [around] and talk (Sh** beeped) they're doing too much time it taken too much time talking(Sh**)  about it
instead of getting up off their [ass] and
Following their dreams because I'm here to [follow] my dreams
You know and help other people follow their dreams and inspire people who are dreamers
It's crazy that we live in a world that if you're super positive and super creative that it's scary
so what does [that] tell you about the mentality [of] most people? if you're scared of like positivity and
creativity? (Kanye to the crowd)so when you're at your lowest point in life, just know there's always hope and
and always know there's a new day always know there's a way. you know people try to tell you your whole life you know"be humble
be humble be humble"when is the last time somebody tried to tell you "Be great"?  "be amazing"
"Be awesome." Oh
Everyone out there in TV. World Real world
Whatever world you stay in needs to know that I've never done a publicity stunt in my life any time
I went up and spoke my mind
Where they put my career in Jeopardy or whatever someone so-called said it was always
What I thought was the truth without my greeting to a teleprompter or whatever whatever I felt emotionally
I don't follow like rules of like you know normal celebrity or what their publicist tells them to say anything
But I say things
The wrong way a lot of times my intention is always positive and I want to bring more things to the world
I want to help the world. I want to make people's lives easier. I said if you guys look at the same interview
It's really something extremely
fearless for someone in my position to do because most people just like you know bow tie on a TV or whatever bow down to
These cameras like I could care less about
Any of these cameras in all honesty all I care [about] is my family
I care about protecting my girl protecting my baby and protecting my ideas and my dreams. Yes
I'm totally weird
And I'm totally honest and I'm totally inappropriate
Sometimes and the thing is I you know for me to say I wasn't a [genius]
[I] would just be lying to you [and] to myself
Okay, so you should be John Stephens
Yeah
It was Kanye west who said change to legend you know the first person actually was a guy named Jay Ivy who's also from
Chicago and his a friend of mine and Kanye's and he's a poet and
we working on Kanye's album, and Kanye was having me sing all these parts and a
Jay Ivy was just like "man, We're gonna have to call you the legend" cuz you know my voice is kind of old-school
I've always had an old soul, Kanye as I'm a should just call yourself John legend and
I
Was like "no, that's ridiculous" Oprah and John laugh.
You know of course kanye's got a new album called yeezus, so he's not afraid
to say big bold things and and you know
"Maybe I'll just roll with this whole John legend thing" and my kind of ultimate deciding Factor was "let's not
Not do it out of fear"
Because  (Oprah) "because you're afraid to call yourself a legend" [oh], yeah, let's not not doing because
Because I'm afraid that it won't work out
Like cuz people could laugh at you if you don't have a good career
And you're going around calling yourself legend you think you now live up to it. I think I'm working on it. I'm on my way
Okay, please thank you
please take a rap on you right now me rapping right now a
Dumpling wrapper this truck right foot right on the bar [guitars] idea right here bring it "hey, Mr.
West my name is cam Gray from the
937 came to annihilate my King Young heavyweight primate young cam grey standing in front of Kanye
I wish you would give me a deal. That's what I needed. [I] swear my whole life is I've been dreaming
That's what I got. I feel it. That's what I got. I made this happen last night. I told my homie this what happened
I told him I'm again at Kanye then we took it do a written go [read] for [high] pressure never like
go far
Doesn't even do bars he responds I
Was born in tennis even my heart stays up in Ohio get my [weed] [from] [a] [few] [cali] be known that for a while
Shake my style mother got a recipe see I'm the best in the midwest better mention me. Yeah, my name is Cam gram
$120 [d]. I couldn't afford from a PC. I'm not dumb man. I got my degree. I got my life together
I got much together come on [Dawg]
Real give me a chance for me
I swear to God man swear to God (Kanye asks Cam)"You be open to start off as like an assistant" man
I'm down and start anything. I just want to learn
(Kanye) You can start somewhere man man. Thank you very much to you. Thank you for your [charter], and thank you very much [Johnny]
[oh], thanks taking the favor Cameron Grey Cameron Grey
so many people are just so( f****beeped)
Obvious they don't even realize [that] when they
Box me in or try to verbally put me in some type of box will put donda in a box that
They're really showing their level of ignorance. They're putting themselves in a box and you
[know] people can write write write all they want, but what are people doing?
and if there's anybody that's out there doing they know how hard it is to [actually] do and I'm like a
motivation of the doers If if
Everything I did failed which it doesn't it actually succeeds, but if everything I did
failed
Just the fact that I'm willing to fail is an inspiration people are so scared to lose that they don't even try
Like one thing that people can't say is they can't say I'm not trying
I'm not trying my hardest
And I'm not trying to do it the best way that I know how
What little information I get I?
Refuse to follow those rules that society is set up in the [way] that they control people with low self-esteem
With improper information with branding with marketing I refuse to follow those rules. It's about truth
It's about information
It's about awesomeness and the only luxury is time the time you spend with your family
That's the only luxury to this concept of luxury is is improper to me when I compare myself to Steve jobs
or Walt Disney Howard Hughes David Stern Michelangelo da Vinci
Jesus or whatever is I'm saying these are my heroes
These are people [that] I look up to this is the type of impact
[I] want to make on the earth if I can make this type of impact up to this point
What can I do if if you call bob iger and say "yo give him a shot" if you call oprah and say "yo?
Back this kid "let's just get this game. This kids kids were his parents were educators
He wants to educate. He wants to look at curriculums, and say how do we simplify that exactly what I did in music
I want to apply to product. I want to apply to education. This is what my company [Donda] is about?
There's a series of theater people who like right? Just negative comments. They [want] to joke around and say why is he still trying?
You know if I see something I see opportunity. I'm gonna go for it
I'm here to crack the pavement and make new grounds. You know sonically and in society
Culturally, we're not always in the position that we want to be at we're constantly growing
We're constantly making mistakes because he's trying to express ourselves [are] trying to actualize our dreams. I want to create something better for you
We have been limited
It's bigger than you know who I am even in this you know in my presence living it's about
You know "when I was on earth. What did I do to help?"
Want [people] to think more?
I want people to feel like
It's [ok] to create and follow what their dreams are and not feel boxed in. I want people to feel like awesome is
Possible there's a lack of creativity in every field
Cuz people are afraid
as
A artist and in this world, we could do whatever we want you know, so you're Gonna. Love me or
You're Gonna Hate me but imma be me
Evan:Thank you guys so much for watching
I love
To know what you think of Kanye west as an entrepreneur if you want to leave a comment below
[I] made this video on Kanye because
Jose Cruz
asked me to so if there's someone you'd like me to make a top 10 list of
Leave it in the comments below as well
And I just might make it .and of course, believe!! thank you for watching I'll see you soon!